buenos días muchísimas gracias por este
espacio a que se debe aún se debe a que
las cifras y la informa más que la cifra
de la información no está disponible no
está organizada y no está accesible
entonces usted habla de 129 personas que
permanecen desaparecidas como bien lo
dice porque la fiscalía si lo reforma
sin embargo la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos ha recibido
información de 132 personas que
permanecen desaparecidas las
organizaciones de la sociedad si por su
parte hablan de más de doscientas
personas han llegado a mencionar más de
400 personas desaparecidas durante el
conflicto durante este conflicto social
el motivo del paro
ustedes han pedido al estado colombiano
que se realice una búsqueda de
localización sin dilaciones de los
desaparecidos cuál ha sido la respuesta
del gobierno cómo está actuando para
ubicar a estas personas
bueno el yo creo que la fiscalía que es
la que tiene que desarrollar la tarea de
la búsqueda de las personas
desaparecidas no ha puesto hoy a
disposición todos los mecanismos
jurídicos que existen para la protección
hay mecanismos como el mecanismo de
búsqueda urgente de personas
desaparecidas las organizaciones han
presentado han reclamado la activación
de este mecanismo y sin embargo este
mecanismo no ha sido aceptado en todas
las ocasiones pero por otro lado la
procuraduría general de la nación y las
personerías que son lentes de control
deben hacer una revisión de los
registros de detención de las personas y
esto no está funcionando adecuadamente y
creo que este es el mecanismo más
adecuado más cierto y más eficaz para
poder saber cuántas son las personas
detenidas si están o no lo están y en
qué lugares se encuentran y por lo tanto
saber sobre quiénes no se tiene
información no se sabe cuál es la suerte
y cuál es el paradero de hecho
y respecto a eso qué opinión les merece
a ustedes el hecho de que el gobierno
colombiano no haya permitido hasta el
momento del ingreso de la cdh al país
cómo puede afectar esto el proceso de
búsqueda
me parece que ante esta situación es
decir que no vengan los mejores ánimos
internacionales que son mecanismos que
fueron reconocidos por el estado cuando
hay asume la responsabilidad de dar
cumplimiento al tratado es un error es
un completo error porque porque una de
las tareas que tienen estos mecanismos
es justamente asesorar a los estados
para cumplir sus obligaciones una
presencia internacional puede apoyar la
búsqueda de soluciones por parte del
gobierno y las autoridades y en
definitiva contribuir a la protección de
los derechos y libertades de las
personas que se encuentran en altísimo
riesgo en este contexto y en el lado
humano de lo que representa este flagelo
qué mensaje le da la desaparición a la
ciudadanía a las familias que se están
viendo afectadas en un país donde
infortunadamente la violación de
derechos humanos es un pan diario desde
hace décadas
pues el mensaje es sumamente grave es
sumamente grave porque es la
reproducción de patrones del pasado que
llevaron a que hoy en colombia se hable
de más de 120 mil personas desaparecidas
durante el conflicto armado durante el
conflicto armado fueron desaparecidas
personas bajo patrones similares a lo
que estamos viendo hoy y es detenciones
por parte de agentes del estado a plena
luz del día sobre las cuales agentes
esos agentes del estado no dan cuenta de
a dónde fueron llevadas las personas las
familias no pueden acceder a información
rápidamente sobre lo que es sobre la
suerte de esa persona luego las personas
son llevadas a lugares que no
necesariamente son de detenciones
regulares como estaba ocurriendo en este
momento y esto el mensaje es que tenemos
que ser firmes como autoridades pero
también como sociedad en exigir que la
no repetición las personas no pueden ser
sometidas a desaparición forzada en este
país
en ninguna parte del mundo muchas
gracias a ustedes y que aparezcan que es
lo más importante